Russia and China just announced that
they're doing like a collab they're
cladding yeah who's feature on who's
that I've been waiting I think it's
China's track and the Russia's featuring
on it yeah he's Pit Bull on it too we
don't know but we know that Snoop Dogg
has definitely been signed I mean you do
a war crime picture that with a Kodak
[Music]
so the international criminal court ICC
issues an arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin whoa over war crimes in Ukraine
you go to jail Putin this is kind of
significant which is why the Russian
government spokesperson says the arrest
warrant has no significance whatsoever
international
criminal court yeah that's what I meant
to say oh it's legit so he's basically
getting a summons he's being served yeah
yeah but then like this who runs it
though is it real like is it like the
U.N
um it is like is it's a body
I feel like you win everyone laughs at
them they're just like international law
it is no this is this is what the
government this is what the the Russian
government's doing right they're they're
treating it like exactly like a U.N
decree like you're like they're like you
and what's their prosecution rate like
what's the success of people that
they've summoned this is the first one
that's a really good question they're
going with a heavy case they were
foreign
jurisdiction you could just not
recognize it does not extradite its
Nationals it's definitely like a media
play right yeah
um that doesn't mean we agree with
Russia [__] you
it's just what is they don't recognize
them so it's not like getting a subpoena
from like your government yeah yeah
um and by the way this has happened
before like like there have been um
United States you know military members
who got subpoenaed for things like from
international criminal court right it's
like what are you gonna do and the bush
administration's like look you know what
I mean
so I know what you mean you know what I
mean
unofficial decree so they're not really
like that good at Prosecuting people or
yeah I mean they just suck they don't
they don't have a very good success rate
with this stuff right it's just a
tattletale Court
um the warrant means that Putin could be
arrested and sent to the Hague right
like the Nazis if he travels to any ICC
member states which aren't none would
that happen
Switzerland I don't think Switzerland
does any I think Switzerland's one of
those countries where like drug dealers
anybody chocolate dealers come through
Switzerland is like your friend like you
get a divorce with your wife and your
friend's like I want to be friends with
you both and you're like yeah
Switzerland yeah I see yeah ICC even if
a country was one was on that list of
countries that could arrest him who
wants to do it that's so scary who wants
to be the one under the hammer like with
with Russian billionaire oligarchs on
your ass like who is really volunteering
to be like I'll be the country that
arrests Putin well but then yeah we'll
do it
but then there's the like there's the um
the contingent of people right who were
like all the Russians can't wait to get
Putin out so maybe you're convinced
enough that like there's a Groundswell
of support from Russia where if he was
gone maybe they wouldn't care
like Saddam when [__] Saddam went
down was there a bunch of Iraqis who
were like [__] you you took my president
well that's because that's because we
successfully destabilized them yeah nice
USA that part hey can I get a little USA
USA thank you guys
easy
so obviously senior um Ukrainian
officials applauded the ICC decision
with the country's prosecutor General
saying it was a historic moment for
Ukraine and the entire international law
system
um and basically he is being you know
um like I said war crimes in Ukraine
um they're basically saying that enough
things happen there's reasonable grounds
to believe that Putin and
this group called levoa Bulova great
band which sounds like a memory
enhancement drug but it's not
they're responsible foreign
[Laughter]
of unlawful deportation and Prejudice of
Ukrainian children so basically sounds
like Warcraft are being taken from
Ukraine right and captured by the
Russian military and so this is being
used no they're kidnapping Ukrainian
kids absolutely
I thought that was like
kid Farmers like taking
for um hit farmers at a game no I made
up the word but it's basically guys that
want to farm kids Harvest kids so they
take and steal all the kids for their
dirty doings it's more stardew Valley
okay what do you mean for the dirty
doings like if they sell them for labor
for brothels whatever they want [__]
that's a dark show
no thanks for saying kid Farmers that
was way Chiller when he said that I
imagine it being like way more
light-hearted though yeah I was like
that is so I was like that's kind of fun
like yeah they're not tractors like
howdy like yeah like they're bicycle
ones yeah yeah they get to play with an
iPad like two hours a day like that TV
show where the kids do tasks I felt like
yeah they're just being cute you know
they're being cute little kids it's
actually great syntax uh so news of the
arrest warrant comes ahead of a planned
State visit to Moscow next week by
Chinese president XI Jin pink so so this
is big we need a few China yeah big news
at the same time right Russia and China
just announced that they're doing like a
collab they're doing collab they're
collabing yeah who's feature on who's
that I've been waiting for this whose
track is this I think it's China's track
and the Russia's hot featuring on it
we'll help you stupid
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh so part of the dark part of this is
like the investigation that has been
launched right they also found crimes
committed against ukrainians on Russian
territory including deported Ukrainian
children who were prevented from
reuniting with their families there's
what they call a filtration system aimed
at single app singling out ukrainians
for detention and torture and inhumane
detention conditions see that's gnarly
yeah whoa yeah that's real life stuff
yeah that's really sad dude so what you
guys want to talk about kid Farmers
again what other jobs they would have I
was thinking about like kids that grow
like carrots yeah yeah let's think about
the characters like a Fisher Price home
yeah and we're just like oh look at that
yeah hey when I see little kids with
like Fisher-Price McDonald's sets that's
kind of a kid farmer yeah pretty much or
like a kid cook where they're like
making hamburgers yeah Fisher-Price
kitchen you know kind of love Fisher
Price what would Whoopi Goldberg have to
say you're reminiscing up Whoopi is she
still alive
yeah good Lord how dare you how dare you
Sister Act three pre-production oh yeah
they're making that huh
I thought they were I love Sister Act
well she's in the new Star Trek
apparently oh that's that's good well
there's a there's a show called Picard
which is like basically the end of Star
Trek in a dark way he's like wasn't it
Whoopi who said when they on The View
when they were talking about Ukraine
versus Russia what'd she say and she was
like isn't that just like whites against
whites oh yeah oh right the Nazis the
Holocaust stuff she was like it wasn't
even that bad
yeah that's even worse so yeah that's
what she said that's what she said yeah
something about like it's not as bad as
slavery because that was just like why
is everyone so mad about the house oh
gosh that's what she said like Jerry
Seinfeld she said yeah yeah what's the
deal well that's what's still that's
what Jerry said too yeah
and I got an Applause break yeah that
hit show well then it got it
oh Jesus that sounds Wild
Joe what's your take on Ukraine and
Russia whose team are you on yeah who
are you rooting for five seconds to
decide we can cut it if you want I'm
team
um America yeah because at the end of
the day oh America is that new type of
America
so you know the Game of Thrones right so
sometimes countries have to do something
to stay on top of the game and then like
when you see these plays being played
out you're like oh but you know where
it's happening you know to be a leader
of a world you have to you have to do a
lot of dirt and then I see what's
happening and I go oh but then my you
know this is to so I can live like this
and play with my games yeah you know so
you don't want to be a player hitter
really yeah hey player I can't judge
where I'm reaping the benefits of being
the most richest powerful country that's
fair because real bits of benefits yeah
we're not giving anything back but
that's why we we say down with
capitalism and stuff yeah
well on our iPhones right yeah yeah so
it's to me I just feel hypocritical yeah
I have to fight capitalism the
revolution no choice there's nowhere
else to fight it do you think that
there's any Merit to this summons that
they're giving them nope I think it's
like it's like when they say like Saddam
turn yourself in and he's like yeah okay
if you remember two couple days before
the Iraq War they're like sadab turn
yourself in okay piece of [__] come out
with your hands up and [__] turn
yourself off and he's like yeah dude I'm
coming oh yeah
[Laughter]
anyone actually does
like they told some dictator you know in
some little country the warlord was like
all right I will do it that's that's how
they actually got it probably the
president of Sri Lanka would do that
[__] some little [__] like that
yeah exactly sounds like a good song
it sounds like an accordion player to me
geez yeah
instrument right he's like oh I am
coming out but my hands cannot be up I
am playing see it going in and it's like
okay we got this Southern [__] dead the
rights take him out with a sniper please
foreign